you want a divorce yes okay divorce
90-day fiance couple Carini Martin's and
Paul still are calling it quits after
two years of marriage the pair
separately revealed the decision to the
public on Monday and Tuesday
home the two first met online and
sparked a romance before style traveled
to Brazil to meet his ladylove face to
face their meeting and relationship was
featured on TLC's 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days and 90 day fiancé the
other way they eventually died the not
in November 2017 Martins also gave birth
earlier this year to the couple's son
Pierre very very bad what's the best
solution to this she confirmed the split
to Us Weekly today commenting yes I am
looking for a lawyer now Martin's
announcement comes one day after style
posted a cryptic Instagram which
appeared to reference their separation I
want to keep this together because I
love you earlier today he took to
Instagram again to seemingly reveal
plans to convince Carini and Pierre to
stay in the u.s. along with the comment
quote I just want the best possible life
for my son this is the second time this
year that style has said he and Martin's
were getting divorced in September he
shared two facebook Carini asked me to
remove our photos and let everyone know
that she doesn't want me in her life
[Music]